We've gotta kick everything off
with a sweet little nostalgic nugget
about Leonardo DiCaprio.
Popsugar reports that Leo's former interior designer,
Meghan Weaver, just revealed that his old Malibu beach house
with "Titanic" themed!
It was decked out in "Titanic" towels, a "Titanic" poster,
she would wear the "Titanic" robe around,
and the designer was like, "Wait a minute.
All these 'Titanic' touches?"
She doesn't think they were put there by Leo,
but his proud mama, Irmelin!
How cute is that?
Okay, see, I think it's so cute,
and if I was in like, one of
the highest grossing films of all time,
I would have it, too.
I was in "The Hobbit" in seventh grade.
You guys probably heard about it. I was a revelation.
Which character did you play?
The hobbit!
Oh!
Thank you very much!
And if I could get like, Ross Matthews
as "The Hobbit" bathmat when I was in seventh grade,
I woulda.
Yeah.
Do you have anything in your house?
Nothing.
Anyway, I will say,
What?!
Nothing.
Why not?!
No, it's all in boxes in storage.
I don't need me!
Oh, girl. I would have me everywhere.
I will say, though, that I've actually been
to Leonardo DiCaprio's like, real home,
and he is so not self-indulgent.
There is no me me me.
His taste is impeccable, his art collection's to die for,
and I think this was like, the cutest thing ever,
but he doesn't live like that to my knowledge.
Alright.
Next up, tying with Black History Month,
Google, this is so cool,
they're rolling out a brand new feature
that makes it even easier to support black businesses.
House Beautiful reports that the new feature
is already up and running right now!
You just go to the Google shopping tab
and you search for whatever product you want,
and, in the results, you'll be able to see
which stores are black-owned businesses!
You're looking right there.
They already have this feature in Google Maps, too!
So all your searches of local shops and restaurants
tells you that feature as well!
Like, I'm of the generation
where like, if they ask me for my password,
I just start crying,
(Ross laughs)
but my daughter can like, hack, you know?
So I love this.
It's respectful, it is user-friendly, it's all the things,
and I can't thank Google more.
I really can't. This is perfection.
Because it's what we wanna be doing, you know?
But sometimes it can be confusing.
Like, how do you get from your intention to execution?
This makes it so simple.
I love that, Ross, so much.
Google, intention to execution. Thank you.
And thank you, Ross.
You're welcome.
You just kinda surmised
everything I think and feel!
(Ross laughs)
I love it!
Okay.
I have been very open about my love
of old fashioned snail mail, mm-hm,
and I'm real hot to trot for this suggestion from Vogue!
They say that, this Valentine's Day,
you should make your own Valentine's cards!
Like, DIY it!
They just makes such a difference, you know?
They do.
I was thinking, like, when's the last time I wrote like,
a love letter or something, and it's like, never.
I've never done it, so I'm gonna do it this year.
Let's do it, Rossie!
And he's watching.
Act surprised, babe, when you get it, okay?
Makin' it for you.
But I started by making you a Valentine's Day card.
Rossie!
I did.
This is what I made.
Oh my God.
It's so awesome.
Okay,
I'm gonna hand it to you.
Okay, and you can put it down.
There you go. Okay.
(laughs) I know, it looks like a toddler did it,
but I actually did do that.
This was exactly what I was picturing
when I was saying, like, those handmade cards!
Oh my gosh, I love it so much, I can't even handle it!
Okay.
Okay. Make me something!
I'm going to, because, look, I pulled this from home.
I just had some like, water color tubes
that's like, the highly pigmented
and you add a little water to it,
so you just do some colors,
and I got some white paper,
I got my favorite pair of scissors
and my jar of paint brushes,
and then this is this little caddy I had made for Olive
when she was little.
So cute!
One for her and Frankie.
So, I'm gonna DIY you a love Valentine's!
You know what?
The things that are handmade are special.
Like, they're the ones that I've saved for my entire life.
I still have them.
(upbeat music)